I'm really excited.
We've got two beautiful demonstrations to show you once the real
classic, the ammonia fountain, the other one is completely new.
One we've invented ourselves called Neil's balloon.
They're both based on the fact that ammonia gas is very soluble in
water. And when it dissolves in water, the water gets alkaline.
So if you put in an indicator that is colorless in
water and red in alkaline, when the ammonia goes in,
the water gets right and we use the indicator. Finnell thirdly,
the classic experiment is called the ammonia fountain.
It consists of a large glass bulb filled with ammonia,
which has a cook or bang in the bottom with a glass tube going
through it about halfway up the flask.
And the idea is if you put the bottom of the tube into water,
the ammonia starts dissolving in the water.
It creates a partial vacuum because you're absorbing gas.
And so the pressure is going down and the pressure of the atmosphere pushes more
water into the flask, more ammonia dissolves. So more water goes in.
Now the problem was we set it all up.
Neil set it all up people to Monier into the flask ammonias light to the
nails. So you can just fill the flower skin up by putting the tube inside of it.
And he then put the bung into the flask.
And then before we started,
we had the tube just above the surface of a large jar of water.
And enough ammonia was coming out to start triggering the
indicator and the most beautiful red threads
started appearing in the jar. I was so excited. I nearly wanted to stop there.
Then we learned the tube into the water,
but there wasn't enough difference in pressure to get it
started.
So Neil and I decided to pour some liquid nitrogen over the top,
which cooled the ammonia reduced its pressure,
and therefore began to suck in the water.
And once the water started going in, it was really beautiful.
[Inaudible] ever seen it before.
Slight problem that the bang hadn't been pushed in quite hard enough.
So little air was leaking in as well, but that caused bubbling,
which probably added to the effect. And for reasons,
they don't quite understand that as it went on the form of
the liquid film that was on the glass surface changed a
bit.
So there was an ever-changing patterns and also the color of the indicator
changed quite a bit. So it was really nice before we go onto the next one,
just let me remind you the reaction here is ammonia dissolving in
water, making it slightly alkaline.
And the red color is not part of the reaction.
That's an indicator to show you that the water is alkaline.
The next demonstration already.
It's an experiment because we didn't know whether it would work began with my
idea that we should try filling a balloon with ammonia because
ammonia is lighter than the air.
So I just wondered whether a balloon as ammonia would float,
not something you'd want to use as the party,
because if it bursts they'd be smell,
but it does float quite nicely.
Then we remembered that if you put sticky tape onto a
balloon,
you can then stick a pin or a needle through the tape,
into the balloon without bursting it.
The reason for this is that when you normally prick a balloon,
when you make the first hole,
the fabric runs from that hole and its
slit goes up through the fabric and it breaks.
But if you have the rubber held by sticky tape, it can't move.
So we had the idea that we should try injecting water with
fin of Darlene into the balloon.
What we hoped was that the water would absorb the
ammonia. So the pressure would go down and the balloon would shrink,
of course, with the fountain, the size of the flask can't change.
And of course it fills up with just more and more water.
So the idea here was be a much simpler demonstration that we could do perhaps
more quickly before we started filming Neil practiced with a
syringe needle in the nitrogen balloon,
just sticking the needle in, it worked perfectly.
But then when we started filming,
the first balloon needle went in, there was no more bang
and we will run out to the room because the smell of ammonia,
the ammonia disperse is very quickly, so it's not dangerous.
[Inaudible].
So for the third time I suggested we went to settle a tape or scotch tape
rather than plastic tape.
And we use the bigger needle.
So we could inject the liquid faster. And it worked beautifully
When the liquid went in,
the ammonia started being absorbed and the balloon beautifully shrank.
But what we didn't realize because Neil was holding,
it was that when ammonia dissolves in water,
it produces a lot of heat.
There is a positive heat of dissolution,
a heat of reaction.
So the balloon was actually getting hotter and hotter and Neil nearly
dropped it.
However he managed to hang on till the balloon went from this sort of size to
about the size of my class plans.
We were all really very pleased in a way it's a nicer demonstration to show how
the gas is disappearing into the liquid.
Then the traditional emerg new fountain, because in that,
the size of the floss doesn't change,
but really both of them have fun.